[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday the american rescue plan which
became law
in march was supposed to deliver
billions of dollars in aid and loan
forgiveness to the nation's
underprivileged farmers
instead those funds are being held up by
a federal lawsuit
the promise of aid that fails to
materialize is all too familiar to many
farmers of color
long subjected to discrimination in
government programs
we went to virginia to talk with a
fourth generation black
farmer leading the call for change
john boyd has been tilling this soil for
the last three decades
land that's been in his family for a
hundred years
my grandfather was able to raise 15
children on his farm
you say you're the classic case yes of
the black farmer
the classic case why many black farmers
uh
were tied historically to the land
either through
sharecropping or generational land
that's the way the blacks
did it and we were old school farmers
these are our tobacco curing bones
boyd is president of the national black
farmers association
representing thousands of black farmers
across the u.s
we farm with limited resources banks
weren't lending us any money
usda really dog black farmers and poor
processing time we took 387 days to
process a black farm loan request in
less than 30 days
to process a white farm loan request
in march president biden announced his
plan to right that
wrong providing 4 billion dollars in
loan relief to socially disadvantaged
farmers
and ranchers in his 1.9 trillion dollar
american rescue plan
this debt relief is designed to catch
them up we spoke to agriculture
secretary tom vilsack in april about
disparities in the last year alone
in the covert relief packages that were
announced prior to the rescue plan
of those self-identified farmers who
identified as white or black or hispanic
black farmers received roughly 20
million dollars in help
through those covered packages white
farmers received over five and a half
billion dollars
and the reason for it is because they
were able to grow over a period of time
over the over the decades able to fully
utilize
the full extent of usda programs black
farmers were not able to do that because
of discrimination
but last week a federal judge in
wisconsin
halted those payments saying the u.s
department of agriculture's use of
race-based criteria in the
administration of the program
violates their right to equal protection
under the law
it's one thing to help people because
they themselves have been the victim of
identifiable past discrimination
but it's a wholly other thing to hand
out benefits
or to grant the preference based solely
on the color of one's skin
rick eisenberg is the president of the
wisconsin institute of law
and liberty the firm representing 12
white farmers across
nine states that challenge the policy
so you don't argue that systemic racism
has perhaps disadvantaged black farmers
in the past
certainly there have been some farmers
who have been black farmers who have
been discriminating
against in the past there was a lawsuit
the way to stop discriminating on the
basis of race is to stop
discriminating on the basis of race and
not to think
that there is some way that we can
balance the scales
by discriminating just a little bit the
usda
isn't backing down telling cbs news
we respectfully disagree with this
temporary order
and will continue to forcefully defend
our ability to carry out this act of
congress
and deliver debt relief to socially
disadvantaged borrowers
i wasn't aware that
some farmers weren't receiving the same
as other farmers
cheryl ash and her husband james are
plaintiffs in the suit
they breed hogs in jasper missouri
they're only about four days old
i didn't know that existed but i think
it doesn't matter
what color of skin you have if you're a
farmer you should be able to qualify
and and get those programs and those
grants
equality is best especially from our
government
at the turn of the last century there
were nearly 1 million
black farmers in america the usda now
says
there are only 45 000 in a country of
3 million farmers and less than 40
percent of them 17 000
qualify for assistance at the bottom
they would use old rocks from the farm
for boyd those numbers showcase decades
of discrimination and disparity
that he pledges he will fight to remedy
well let me say this uh
i'm gonna die a farmer i'm very
optimistic
about the future but i want people to
know
that uh it's not gonna happen by itself
well the department of agriculture is
going to answer the suit they are
essentially advising borrowers to to
just move forward with their claims
but as we speak there are some five
other lawsuits that are already coming
down the pike
look the big question here is whether or
not these black farmers farmers of color
should have a remedy for those years
decades
of discrimination that the usda
acknowledges
there have been lawsuits uh but
oftentimes they aren't
fully paid out and i think everybody
agrees equality is best as she said
there's just a question of how you
actually get there
right and and what was the inequality
earlier and how do you
can you make up for that look it's tough
it's tough it's not just this industry
when it's
here when it's unfair when when you see
unfairness out there it
it's not pretty right and so now i think
everyone sees a taste of it the question
is
you know like years and years how do you
remedy that how do you remedy it